Aunque las computadoras cuánticas no son adecuadas para resolver
todos los problemas, hay algunas clases de problemas
y posibles casos de uso donde esperamos
que la computación cuántica tenga un impacto.
Entre ellos están la simulación, como
el modelado de procesos y sistemas que ocurren en
la naturaleza; la búsqueda y optimización,
que consiste en encontrar la mejor o
la solución óptima en una situación con
muchas respuestas posibles; y las matemáticas
y el procesamiento de datos con estructura compleja,
incluidas aplicaciones para el aprendizaje automático.
Los algoritmos cuánticos adoptan un nuevo enfoque para
este tipo de problemas, aprovechando
las características únicas de la física cuántica, como
la superposición, la interferencia y el entrelazamiento.
Las computadoras convencionales se atascan
al explorar ciertas áreas del espacio computacional,
por lo que no pueden encontrar estos patrones.
Las computadoras cuánticas están equipadas con
capacidades adicionales o un mayor rendimiento
para algunos problemas gracias a su naturaleza cuántica.
Para comprender plenamente el potencial de las computadoras cuánticas
se requiere profundizar en la teoría de la complejidad computacional,
una rama de las ciencias de la computación que se centra en
medir y comparar el esfuerzo computacional que
supone resolver distintos tipos de problemas.
Esto proporciona un marco útil
para describir las distintas mejoras de velocidad
y las clases de problemas que se encuentran en
la computación.